this week convict zone is in the British
city of Cambridge and my guest is one of
India's best-known politicians the MP
Shashi Tharoor in 2014 his Congress
party was handed its worst-ever
national election defeat since when it's
gone on losing does this the party of
the Gandhi dynasty deserve to survive
[Music]
shashi tharoor welcome to conflict zone
good to be with you again to 2014 your
Congress party had its worst-ever
national election defeat the string of
losses has gone on since then it time to
kiss the party goodbye no because though
it was indeed the worst ever electoral
defeat there were a couple of
consolations oddly enough amid the
carnage the first was that we still were
the only party that actually wants
something everywhere in other words
where we'd won 10 or 12 seats with only
one one or two this time around we won
them in the northwest in the southwest
in the Northeast and the heartland but
you lost power in Assam you lost it in
Kerala you didn't get a single seat in
Delhi are you now referring to the
election yes 14 I was talking about
silly since since but since 13 what
we've done what we've done well has been
Bihar where we are in power after a very
long time it's part of a larger
coalition and what we've done
not so well I would suspect is is the
states you mentioned where we had been
in power for some time in
anti-incumbency
is a very powerful factor if you have a
losing ticket a proven losing ticket
with Sonia Gandhi and Rahul Gandhi you
have a man in certain Rahul Gandhi who
clearly doesn't even want to be in
Parliament does he I don't think that's
a fair criticism I've actually as one of
the worst attendance records doesn't he
worst attendance records Parliament is a
forum that he has increasingly used more
effectively than in the past and so his
recent attendance record is actually
pretty good but more impersonal national
average is 81 since 2014 is attendance
rate was 54% number of questions asked
zero private member's bills zero a below
average MP by every measurement except
that he's also a party leader he has
organisational responsibilities around
the country and sometimes he's a winning
ticket Shashi Tharoor is he he's not a
winning ticket allowing ticket well as I
said he has won in the past and can win
again how many train wrecks does can
this party absorb we're looking we are
certainly going
through a pretty bad phase of our
existence but we believe we have what it
takes to come back we have the right
values and principles we have a long and
pedigreed history we have a presence
throughout the country we are still a
party with a national footprint
something nobody else can say with his
leadership facing a court case
allegations of illegally acquired land
Supreme Court said the other day this
case should go ahead cases can well go
ahead but nobody has been found guilty
of anything it's very easy I'm afraid in
our country to file charges but in this
particular case and I think you're
referring to what's known as the
National Herald case where a party
newspaper the National Herald was
transferred from a larger collective set
of individual owners to a smaller group
controlled by the party system it's a
rabid land acquisition it's a little row
about the position of a newspaper which
of course if they want a case of
Washington and the Supreme Court refused
to do that they wanted to quash it
without it's not a great recommendation
is it to have that against the
leadership aren't you sick of dynastic
parties and dynastic rule in India
people passing it from one member of the
family to the other is like handing
around the soup plates at dinner isn't
it but hasn't it's gone on long enough
in India the problem Tim is that it's
going on and pretty much every party so
that it's very difficult to single one
out and say you shouldn't be doing this
what I've discovered about Indian
politics having entered it is that a
great deal of what you and I might
consider to be not the best democratic
practice is so deeply entrenched in our
culture that it's infected our politics
as well but your party was in power
longer than anybody else
since independence and did nothing about
this you've got a figures compiled in
two thousand twelve hundred percent of
Indian MPs under the age of thirty were
hereditary a hundred percent a family
business and there aren't very many MPs
under the age of thirty to begin right
two thirds of Indian MPs under the age
of forty were from political families
when you get to women it was even worse
just under seventy percent of women MPs
came into politics on their family
connections know through family
I mean look since fortunately for this
purposes of this conversation I can
assure you that I have never had anybody
in my family in politics in either
direction nor do I have any children who
are interested in inheriting what I've
said I'm there because of my personal
convictions let me see it don't think
that's how family is situated if
families invade this profession - does
not objectively seem ideal but it's
rampant throughout all of it your salary
had more time than any other party to do
some things in my service there were
three three thousand years we have
Bollywood film stars who are the sons of
Bollywood film stars
we have dentists were the sons of
dentists we have carpenters or the sons
of carpenters ours has become a culture
that's other kind you have a voice
sitting in Parliament September 2013 the
Hindu reported that 30% of sitting MPs
and 31% of those in the Legislative
Assembly Manoj are facing criminal
charges against them and this continues
to this day and your party is as bad in
this if not worse than the BJP actually
the the current percentages put us well
below the BJP on this particular area
I don't think so Shashi Tharoor I don't
think so in the most elections this year
in the Punjab elections this year 8
percent of your party's candidates faced
serious criminal charges the BJP clocked
up 4% in the Goa he had fewer candidates
because then other content we're looking
at the percentage we're looking at the
percentage of candidates in Goa 16
percent of your candidates facing
serious charges 8 percent of the BJP s
author icons 17 percent of your
candidates accused of serious crime and
we're not talking about parking offences
here we're talking about murder charges
extortion attempted rape crimes against
women and their sitting in Parliament
well the facing these series changed him
until they found guilty it is wrong to
conclude that these charges are
legitimate and that's precisely why in a
few cases thank god the figures are
lower than the 30 percent we first
talked about from from the earlier
election in a few cases candidates from
the party judges deserve the benefit of
the doubt because of their Publix not
according to the Electoral Commission
they don't in 1998 2004 the Commission
recommended that candidates charged with
serious offenses be disqualified
even before conviction and in 2013 the
Verma Commission recommended the same
your party along with all the others
refused to heed the advice no the courts
went the other way and said that anybody
who is convicted will be instantly
disqualified from Parliament and indeed
people have been in the old days what
would happen is you'd be convicted and
then you'd file an appeal and on the
basis of the appeal you'd continue in
politics for years rather democracy
would tolerate having 30% of its
parliamentarians facing criminal charges
you want the badge of the world's
largest democracy this isn't the way to
earn it is a Tim this is why I feel that
people with my sort of background should
also come into politics that we should
have educated professionals also
entering the fray view our government
minister in your party then you didn't
do anything about this or anything about
that we didn't even raise your voice
against it did you I've written books
raising my voice against this reading
there from midnight to the Millenium
I've decried this 20 years ago but the
fact is with all the years that your
party was in power you you cemented this
unbreakable nexus of politicians and
corrupt business now you cemented it you
know going to going on to a different
tack criminal charges are one thing
corrupt practices with business are
another I've decried that too but that's
a different phenomenon that but it sunk
it was cemented during years of Congress
party rule wasn't it unfortunately every
party is complicit I wish one could say
that one party was Morgan that's not a
great excuses one one person murders
somebody so it's okay for other people
to do it no you know that's not but I
mean you are saying that you're excusing
you know what I'm saying is to single
out the Congress party for political
corruption is laughable you were in
power most of the time and those who are
in power sadly in various states have
been pretty much every party in India's
held power somewhere or the other have
unfortunately all faced these charges
it's partly because our system has
adopted a certain hypocrisy of
unrealistically low legal expense limits
which makes every
party seek which nobody buys sky anyway
exactly so they seek and spent
unaccounted funds and the generation of
those unaccounted funds is often the
root of corruption but I have tried this
and I declared it in Parliament by the
way in speeches in Parliament I have
said that we cannot remain silent about
political corruption and talk about
black money as if it's only coming out
of real estate transactions and things
like that
Yamashita Roe has performed
significantly worse on financial
transparency than the BJP during the
financial years between 2004 5 and 2014
and 15 83% of your body's total income
came from unknown sources compared to
65% of BJP so you you don't obey the
rules that there are there the rules are
full of loopholes aren't they and that's
why they need to be changed and in fact
one of the proposals we just come up now
is that the anonymous donations have to
be kept at a much lower thing I think
it's 2,000 rupees rather than 20,000
rupees who's going to who's going to pay
that former Prime Minister Atal Bihari
Vajpayee was often quoted as saying
every legislator starts his career with
the lie of the false election return he
files you have a file a false election
return well not knowingly but I said you
mean not knowingly you didn't have
responsibility for the ones no because
you see what happens is you spend the
money that you are legally able to raise
and spend and that's what I sign my
election expense sheets fall but I have
to admit that I believe there are people
spending money on my behalf including my
party and it's and it's and it's agent
is your responsibility isn't it fact is
everybody else is doing it if I didn't
do it I would be so it's alright for me
to break the rules cause everybody knows
it's break I think it's important to
amend the rules and be realistic about
them I think we really have to raise the
legal expense limits that people would
actually be able to legally raise and
spend accountable funds that are
actually reasonable to enjoy your party
along with all the others doesn't it
show ever a great respect for rules in
2012 you had a discussion at the
think-tank no to you personally but MPs
from both Congress and BJP discussed
spending some 3.3 million dollars to win
seats where the official limit was
$26,000
they're you and they did it openly so
that you even pretend to abide by
I don't need how do you reach two
million people which is what the average
MP represents with $26,000 the initial
sim is the hypocrisy of the low expense
limit which has been pegged at that
level in order to demonstrate that ours
is a polity where the per to can but you
may say the rules are unrealistic but
you're sending you're sending a signal
that okay we don't care anymore about
the rules or the laws the new people out
there anyway what an example to set for
the rest of India unfortunately well the
largest democracy as I said
unfortunately the problem remains that
if you choose not to reach your 2
million voters you will not be
successful in politics so you have to
reach them by whatever means you can
with whatever help you can get and
unfortunately very often this has
implied people doing corrupt things
raising unaccounted money or what's
called black money money on which taxes
haven't been paid and which are not
declared in your election expense
returns and that's what mr. Vajpayee was
referring to don't forget mr. Vajpayee
it's a prime minister from the BJP party
relying all parties are equally
absolutely but let's go back to
something you said February 2014 you
wrote that the UPA the congress-led
government had demonstrated a commitment
to accountability and transparency had
taken unprecedented measures to bring
transparency into India's or the right
proportion and often opaque systems by
the end of its term your government was
drowning in one high-profile corruption
scandal after another wasn't it and you
pride yourself on transparency let's not
rewrite history earlier under your
government became a byword for
corruption internationally didn't it
well let me say that the reference in my
in my statement that you quoted was
above all to the Right to Information
Act under which any Indian citizen can
put a letter on a postcard or a sheet of
paper and have information made
available about every penny of taxpayers
money being spent or misspent by the
government what about ensuring that the
conduct of elected officials is indeed
made
so it isn't the first scandals it didn't
affect these huge financial scandals
that your government was a trade just a
common the Commonwealth Games for
instance in 2010 gendered up costing 18
times its original budget look Central
Vigilance Commission said around 1.8
billion dollars have gone astray the
telecom scam what - for votes but the
question is Tim there's been an
opposition party in power for the last
three years why has no one been
convicted of these scams really well
what they were portrayed as being a lot
of this was also media exaggeration it
was in current as this government has
actually issued telecom spectrum
e-commerce on a thirty nine billion
dollars it was probably one of the
largest if not one of the largest scams
in India's is that is wider than this
governed make thirty nine billion
dollars when it conducted it's telling
your telecom minister mr. Roger was
arrested in 2011 was out on bail in 2013
well he's still facing charges and if
he's guilty so is this a press
exaggeration when WikiLeaks released a
leaked cable from the American Embassy
describing how a senior congress party
aid showed an embassy official u.s.
embassy official chests of cash
allegedly to be used to support a key
vote of confidence in 2008 when your
Congress party was in power was that
press exaggeration this was made like
what came in Indian politics in 2008 I
was in the yellow joint but your party
but but I do or RT what I can say about
party was I was a bit surprised of these
things did happen at that time is
because it's you know something which
has been widely talked about but indeed
the people in power of that time are no
longer heading the Varis party did you
think that when you went to the polls in
2014 that India wouldn't notice these
huge scandals and punish you accordingly
did you really think you get away with
it all well I think a number of factors
came in to the rejection by the voters
there was everything from
anti-incumbency to hyperinflation
because a lot hyperinflation but severe
inflation because of global fuel prices
as well as indeed they were punishing
ruins
shashi tharoor they were punishing you
made a massive corruption
many of my colleagues suffered I did win
reelection so all I can say is that I
was able to demonstrate enough of a
record of accomplishment on the ground
you held your seat I a message and
Congress was decimated
well Congress Congress actually I think
is more than a seat to the Parliament
and that's their attempt less than a
tenth you were a very senior UN official
under secretary general communications
public information in the UN an
organization that holds Human Rights
dear but when you got back to India
and you asked about Kashmir you ask this
about an interview in a year ago and you
talked about human rights abuses and you
said rather casually as far as the
wrongs in Kashmir are concerned Indians
have been the first to acknowledge them
to take action it's not true is it
ladies I wouldn't have said it if it
wasn't because the people who
contradicted you wear your own
governments group of so-called
interlocutors who reported in 2012 what
they called the failure to bring to book
those guilty of human rights violations
this is the committee of three the three
wise men are friends of mine and oh yeah
who reported that you weren't doing your
job that you weren't bringing these
people to book so for you to say that as
far as the wrongs in Kashmir concerned
Indians of act they didn't did they
there isn't a single crime or
misbehavior even in Kashmir that hasn't
first been exposed by an Indian
individual by an Indian personal
Authority by an Indian media person or
by an Indian NGO in other words Indians
are the first to bring these up it's
impossible but this is a wrongdoing
variance with the human rights groups
with the State Department in 2010 which
said several laws including part of the
Criminal Procedure Code and the Armed
Forces special Pazza
were used to provide legal protection
for members of security forces who
violated Human Rights officers at all
levels acted with impunity and officials
rarely held them accountable for illegal
actions this tells a very different
story from yours every single human
rights abuse has been investigated by an
Indian
it's simply not they've been exposed
they've been investigated the issue here
is whether they've been punished
adequately and this becomes a real
challenge I know that our soldiers have
been cashier there are court martials
that have taken place there have been
serious and they being mass grave was
discovered people who had disappeared
Adly one of the realities in kashmir is
that the armed forces and the
authorities are blamed for a number of
the actions undertaken by terrorists
people are too scared to blame the
terrorists because they fear for their
own lives so they blame the military in
March 2012 your National Human Rights
Commission told the UN Special
Rapporteur for extrajudicial executions
I'm sure you know him Christopher Hines
that from time to time extrajudicial
executions have become virtually a part
of state policy that is your National
Human Rights Commission let's be clear
naturally mean because it's certainly
not part of state policy have become
actually a bother stir let's be clear
you were a state then that was being
accused by your own National Human
Rights Commission of murdering its own
people that's what this says well no no
torture is torture those repression
there's lack of frei there are there are
there are searing conversations about
some of these things that take place
that it is not an India's interest to
display publicly outside because it's
not as aware in some sort of living room
situation we are facing an onslaught by
terrorists trained armed equipped and
sent across the border by a malign
military establishment in Pakistan this
is not maybe intention whatever you're
meeting your meeting with no respect
whatsoever for human rights and for
constant violations and torture which
have been laid at the door of the Indian
do you think generally those are human
rights you claim to be a democracy they
exactly
thank you for democracy so you have
filed it to a different stand and we do
unless you're quite prepared to be in
the same pot as the terrorists and and
your government terrorists but if you
are murdering your people as the
National Human Rights Commission has
said then maybe firing I think then
maybe you are in the same pot as the
terrorists
that's going far too far as you realize
aren't you ashamed of India's record in
Kashmir on Shashi Thoreau no even when
your instructor has been there have been
very very major mistakes made at various
stages including political mistakes and
there are some deplorable cases of poor
conduct on the part of of armed
personnel including particularly our
armed police who haven't often been
trained adequately but they're also very
many good examples of outstandingly
responsible supportive behavior towards
the local population of which I can give
you many examples well um you're
interlocked you're singling out certain
details which in the course of an
ongoing 25-year war in pause de pon us
with a terrorist onslaught that have
been taking innocent civilian lives as
well as military lives day after day if
you sometimes find that there is an
overreaction or a trigger-happy young
constable somewhere killing somebody if
there's a shocking and it's wrong little
more than that Shashi Tharoor as you
well know and your friends the
government-appointed group of
interlocutors was good enough to list
some of the wrongs that India has
visited on Kashmir in recent years they
listed them rigged elections the
dismissal of elected governments and
installation of pliant ones the arrests
of popular leaders the choking of
dissenting voices through harsh laws the
detention of political prisoners without
the process of law so I ask you again
are you proud of India's record in
Kashmir I can tell you what that's not a
proud proud is the fact that free and
fair elections have been held despite
and all rigged elections yet rigged
elections there was a look at this
rotten election rigged in 1987 that's
what they refer to I know they were just
nothing I was just referring to one
there have been none since then and then
no one has suggested that there been
international observers even the
militant parties have not accused these
elections because he's a huge stain of
India's democracy isn't enough it would
be if it were telling you that the
elections of 87 were a huge mistake and
they were rigged undoubtedly in and
undoubtedly this was certainly one of
the mistakes had sparked off
the disillusionment of some young people
who then became militants but there is
no clear resident popular leaders the
detention of political prisoners without
the process of law these are serious
charges for a country that claims to be
the world's largest democracy what does
this any of this got to do with
democracy it claims with my mama talk
about written plundering you still
employ in India many of the laws and
practices from the British occupation
are you proud of that - no but you
called them obnoxious are you proud that
you still have a block that's why I was
posing them I'm trying to get them
reformed she I'm not magic you haven't
had much success haven't any not success
but that's why you must become for the
right even if you don't see why didn't
India follow up on its promises to
ratify the UN Convention Against Torture
and the UN Convention against it's not
displaced people but it's disappeared be
torture was ratified I was in Parliament
I was broken dead when was it when was
it ratify 2010 then why have we since
had I'm glad don't think it has been
ratified absolutely been signed it's
been signs mean sign you were welcome
for that the UN cannot again I was a
mess up in the government and it does
not be rare for you but I myself wrote
to the Home Minister about the failure
to ratified the bill was brought into
Parliament in 2010 and I 2013 the
newspapers were writing it I said it had
me but I was there when it passed so
whether they've been some Gazette
notifications that have been issued I
don't know but as far as Parliament is
concerned it passed do you still think
that your party deserves to survive
given all the human rights abuses and
corruption that you know it's like
saying do you think somebody deserves to
survive because he's got a wart on his
face or a pimple on his nose it's a bit
more than that no it's not a bit more
there's a far more important things a
party stands for it stands for the
pluralist identity of India it stands
for the values of the freedom struggle
it stands for social justice in a
country where 70% of the people's to
live under $2 a day
it stands for the distribution of the
profits of government while standing
also for the growth that has enabled
India to be
come one of the right now the third
largest economy in the world all of
which have also been important things to
be proud of the Congress party inherited
from the British in India with 90% of
the population living under the poverty
line today it's 26 it inherited in India
with 17% literacy today at 72 he'd
inherited India with life expectancy of
27 today that 70 that some progress has
been made in the Congress party ruled
India for much of the time this progress
was being made let's not write all that
off very good to have your own complex
thanks very much indeed thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]